What do we mean by operating system structure? What we mean by this term is
the way the operating system software is organized
with respect to the applications that it serves
and the underlying hardware that it manages. It's
sort of like the burger between the buns.
There is application at the top and technology
or hardware at the bottom and system software
of the operating system is what connects
the applications to the underlying hardware. Since
this lesson is all about operating system structure, I would like to get your
thoughts on why you may think that the structure of an operating system is
important, and from that point of view I'm going to give you a quiz again.